[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i'm i i have my holy grail
this is one of those statues that uh
you kind of use as a cornerstone
to your collection uh an apex piece
a a piece that you feel uh fits the mold
that you can say is kind of untradable
something that you've been seeking to
obtain a statue
where you can put another statue that's
supposedly in its class
and it outclasses them today
i bring you xm studios
masterpiece line og
iron man
i can't tell you how bad i wanted this
piece
first i want to give a uh shout out to
todd
from spec fiction because when i was
first looking for this piece
uh trust me man the prices on ebay
this is before i was a part of uh
darth castle x uh you know that i do on
friday nights at 9 00 pm
uh dcx uh statute group and they taught
me a lot
they taught me a lot you know um i feel
basically without them you know i would
have
spent excess money on things
sorry and
they have taught me
how to search properly put me in
connections with the right people
so spec fiction definitely
helped me obtain one of my holy grails
and let me give you the story on
why this statue means so much
to me right because
for a long time um
i always had the question who armor was
better
dr dooms or iron man and i grew up in a
day where
it wasn't like mark 5 mark 6 mark 7 all
these little
weird numbers i said mcu stuff i grew up
in the days
where if iron man had a different armor
it was called the stealth armor
if iron man had a space suit it was
called the space armor underwater armor
you know stuff like that and
this armor is his classic armor had the
briefcase
uh he has uh the repulsor rays which is
his gauntlets that he puts on and then
he puts on his boots
he puts on his uh his helmet and his
his pants and the battery packs on each
side
and that was iron man
jet across the world um his repulsor
rays
were absolutely incredible and when he
had to use that unibeam on his chest
you understood that there was trouble to
be held
because he was definitely going to take
you out um
that's when iron man was iron man to me
one of the best stories that i got a
chance to
uh read was iron man 149
and 150 it was iron man versus doctor
doom
and in that issue
you know um iron man was fighting uh
some pirates and
then he had to confront him it was
something that got him all the way to
dome right
so he gets to doom he gets a lot very he
gets to doom's castle
now doom has this is one of his henchmen
that's plotting against
doom himself but he doesn't know it and
doom is a master of the mystic arts
just like doctor strange right so doom
is really good at that
doom is very smart doom has an
insatiable appetite for power right so
his armor is just as top-notch as iron
man so this issue i
i said okay i'm gonna find out exactly
who has
the best armor well they're going
head-to-head and they're fighting
and doom
has a teleportation platform yeah a
teleportation platform
so he goes to jump into the
teleportation platform
iron man jumps in it with him as they're
about to teleport
out doom's henchman jumps out from the
back one of his scientists
and destroys the machine so the machine
is destroyed
these guys is thrusted back in time
into ancient camelot okay
so um i think uh
doom hooks up with mcgorner lefrey
i believe her name is uh she's a
socialist from back then
that was going up against merlin she's
she's very well known later on in comic
books
but uh iron man aligns herself with uh
you know the knights of the round
you know king arthur and doom
brings the army of the dead or zombies
and you know iron man brings
you know the knights around and they're
battling they're fighting
so as they're fighting you know um
they uh get into a tussle
and they realize because at this point
in time the battle is over
right and they realize okay this is a
stalemate here
and we can't you know decide who has the
best armor because
uh uh doom was using like pin particles
like shooting rocks at them that were
growing really big and iron man was
using repulsive shields so it was pretty
much at a stalemate
so they needed to build another
teleportation platform
how they did it they had to trust each
other so one by one they would take
pieces off of their armor
to build this up and they use both their
minds together
to rebuild this teleportation platform
to get back to their proper time
and they did it the battle ended in a
stalemate
and you know at the end you know because
neither one could fly away
iron man walked his way and doom walked
his way and doomed talking crap to iron
man talking about
this isn't over and iron man's like yeah
whatever see you next time get out of
here
so you know that's the reason why
and you know you can tell from the box
of the art in the back
you got merle in there you got iron man
and
you got doom it's a beautiful book
something i urge you to read if you get
a chance
so let's get into this masterpiece of a
statue
um you know i love art prints from xm
studios
uh the art prints are fantastic what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna laminate these
guys
and i'm going to put them you know in
the backgrounds
of this my stuff is still being
finalized you know now
uh shout out to junior for giving me a
little bit of direction
so let's get into the statue well
right here we have the iron man statue
with the portrait of just showing tony
stark's face
but little did i know that it came
with a separate torso with a different
head
two different heads right so now the
difference between
this torso and the other torso is very
minor
but major because back in the days in
the comic books it didn't go over
giant uh revisions what they would do is
change minor little things so
one is a little bit more updated but
this one is more
comic accurate and molded armor to his
skin because you can see his abs
his pecs his uh you know his biceps
everything
the armor is battle worn so
that's a plus for me what i love is in
the middle of his hand
you can see the repulsory bubble
beautiful the arc reactor in his chest
actually comes out for each different
armor
has a different arc reactor one is more
modern the other one is more retro
um i'm not i won't be displaying him
with his face out i just did that for
the
video because you know i just wanted to
you know show the
diversity in it and that's how tony
stark's looks to me
um the fact that he's on a ultron base
you guys know that i think ultron is the
ultimate villain
and ultron this ultron base
probably sealed the deal for me because
xm only did two statues with an ultron
base
um the other is the scarlet witch which
i'm in the
uh talks right now to receive and then
they have a ultron statue itself coming
that's already pre-ordered
but um this ultron base
is magnificent you have two ultron
bodies you have a hand sticking out in
the back
you have other parts of the ultron there
you have tony stark hand holding his
head
and it's just right after a fight a
battle
and you can see the damage on the iron
man
it is absolutely incredible i think xm
blewed out the park i don't think
there's another
another iron man statue in its class
this is a grail this is my grill
and i am so happy i was able to obtain
it
now this is the part in the video where
i'm going to ask you
to like follow subscribe and
hit that joy button hit that join button
you know where that joint button is it's
right there at the bottom hit the join
button
so you can see everything that the realm
is doing right now
this weekend this is the last weekend
and then we're going to be giving away a
playstation 5 and an xbox
series x to some lucky winners
and that is fantastic so if you're a
member of the realm
you definitely have a shot if you're
patreon member of the realm
you have a shot as well if you're both
you have
two shots also go the lords of
gaming.net
where we have a ton of writers ton of
opinion pieces
and we're down with open credit this is
so
incredible that our writers are being
recognized for their hard work
so please give a chance to go there read
all the articles get a chance to look at
old episodes
of kos also combat talk with the king
and iron lord's podcast which i'm a
member of
which is uh sundays at 11 a.m during
football season
well 1 p.m when football season is over
and it's almost over baby stick around
watch this statue in all its glory and
um
this is halloween weekend
next up is something
very spooky stay
collected
[Music]
[Music]
which
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
you